[Music]
buckle your seat belts
we're about to take a ride on the cosmic
super highway
what exactly are these celestial
autobahns how would they help us
explore the furthest parts of our solar
system
and could they change our approach to
mapping the cosmos
forever this is what if
and here's what would happen if we built
a highway
in space i know what you're thinking and
no we aren't talking about laying down
pavement
to build some kind of outer space
freeway
though there is at least one tesla that
would be happy about the idea
the space pathways we're talking about
are called space
manifolds these are arch-like structures
that
emerge from the complicated
gravitational pull between the sun
planets and their moons if you found
yourself
on one of these many interplanetary jet
streams
could you effortlessly cruise our solar
system
or could one wrong turn slam you head
first into jupiter
we've built highways all over earth and
the only thing you need to get started
on your journey
would be a road map when it comes to
space
navigating would be a little more
complicated but
you could save a lot on fuel that's
because you'd be utilizing the concept
of gravity assist this is
a reliable technique that is already
vital to space exploration
if you were on a spacecraft using
gravity assist
you could travel much further than your
launch vehicle could
well launch you imagine using the sun
and planets like
a slingshot to propel yourself around
the solar system
you'd add or subtract momentum by
increasing
or decreasing the energy of your orbit
these techniques have been applied on
previous missions like
voyager 2 this outer planet probe was
launched in 1977
and got a trajectory boost from the
gravitational pulls of
both saturn and uranus and
now it's still speeding through
interstellar space after
more than 40 years of service
but navigating the cosmic super highway
system would be
a little more complicated than using the
gravity of just one planet
these pathways are generated from the
complex gravitational interactions
between all the planets their moons and
the sun
and for starters they're nearly
invisible
if you could spot them you'd be looking
at a network of
tubes swirling along with the planets
but just because they're hard to see
doesn't mean you couldn't try
it would be important to familiarize
yourself with lagrange points
for any two-body system like the earth
and the moon or
the sun and jupiter there are five
locations in space
where gravitational forces between the
two are in equilibrium
or simply balanced if you could place
your spacecraft on one of these points
then you'd be able to remain in a stable
orbit
no need to worry about being pushed
further into space
or being pulled in to crash and
since all two-body systems have these
points
that means our solar system is full of
them
as planets orbit the sun these points
overlap
and intersect so if you're paying
attention you could time things
just right to jump off to another
planet's orbit
hopping through space on these super
highways would allow you to save a lot
of money on fuel
while reaching the outermost parts of
the solar system
at breakneck speeds if you found
yourself
on the right route you could travel the
3.7 billion kilometers from
jupiter to neptune in less than 10 years
but i hope you've got a few years or
even decades to spare
just waiting for these points to overlap
in a good way
and you're still going to need a ship
big enough for all the cargo you'd be
carrying
nasa has estimated that crew of four on
a three-year mission
would need to take more than 10 800
kilograms of food
but if you could use this cosmic highway
trips that usually take hundreds of
thousands of years
could be reduced to several decades
even though scientists have utilized
these manifolds on previous missions
it's unlikely they'll be trying crude
missions
anytime soon to truly understand the
complex
map of connections we'd need to study
many of the
millions of objects floating through
space like comets and
asteroids right you wouldn't want to
smash into the surface of jupiter if
your
calculations didn't add up and this kind
of studying
could help detect potentially dangerous
space objects hurtling along the
celestial autobahn
straight towards earth you know all this
space travel
makes me think maybe instead of space
shuttles or
rockets we could build a tower reaching
all the way out into space
[Music]
i know i know that's a story
for another what if